hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about history of science
and
technology so I see a variety of
questions that have come in here gosh
all sorts of interesting things
um a question from Des
here not particularly my area of
expertise but asks how did taxation work
before money was
invented um I think it was pretty direct
it was like you need to send a person to
fight in our army or you need to deliver
uh kind of this amount of grain to uh um
you know to the the
Imperial you know operative so to speak
I think that was some uh
before before there was a concept of
money I mean then it becomes a lot more
circular and more complicated because
the money is issued by the government
and then you're paying the money back to
the government and so on and it's it's
all a bit more complicated and I know um
uh you know people didn't understand a
lot of how that worked back in Roman
times and things and people would like
print money to pay armies and things
like this and it was all quite confused
uh the the concept of and then they
would print money to pay armies but they
would have sort of in a sense um you
know well printed lists of how much
things cost and you can't both print
money and have a list of how much things
cost because the there's the when you
are printing money you're going to lead
to inflation but then that it's all
rather complicated and and I think was
not well understood and maybe even still
not that well understood all the kind of
M Machinery of economics and so on and I
get the the impression that more is
understood much more has been measured
there are situations like Virtual Worlds
where you can kind of see the flow of
all the money um and where there's at
least a certain amount known about kind
of the the intersection between sort of
human behavior and the Machine of
Economics so to speak but I think that
was not understood until until quite
recently uh stasis asks how did trading
happen between nations that use
different number systems well you know
the big issue was weights and measures
uh that was a thing that you know in
ancient Babylon I mean a lot of our
standardization of things started in
ancient Babylon or Babylonian cities
Like Ur and so on because they were the
places is where cities grew up and you
needed to be much more organized if you
had a city and you needed to be able to
sort of have systematic Commerce you'd
have people coming from other places
trying to buy and sell goods and so on
you needed to standardize things that's
where standardization of calendars well
that was invented multiple times but
standardization of of things like
weights and measures you know I'm
selling you this amount of barlay and uh
you know I will buy uh you
know I don't know what it is two pound
of barley or 20 pound of barley or
something um and it will cost this
number of of credits so to speak but you
have to know what that number of pounds
of barley is and you know when people
were presumably weighing things with
balances and you had to have these sort
of standardized weights and if you
somebody could cheat they could say well
this is a standardized one pound weight
or whatever it is but actually it wasn't
so you had to have this whole elaborate
system which sort of still exists to
today of kind of standardizing the
standards for weights so for example in
the US what used to be the National
Bureau of Standards now the National
Institute of Standards and Technology um
essentially is is
provides ways of standardizing things
like oh I don't know when you buy a
gallon of gasoline is it really a gallon
well that's sort of a that's in the end
that's determined by some standard that
eventually flows all the way back to
nist I think the um uh the co sort of
notion of sort of distribution channel
for weights and measures interesting one
and uh I think that was one of the
things that was sort of established in a
variety of kind of that was something
that the that the state provided I mean
I remember when I was a kid um the uh in
England you know in the US you might
learn about the US Constitution or
something well England doesn't have a
Constitution as such and so school kids
would learn about the Magna carter from
the 1200s which definitely had some
non-modern Provisions in it I mean it
was basically the uh the Barons uh said
to King John or whatever um if you don't
play ball we're going to have a big coup
and so this was kind of a deal made with
them but one of the things that always
used to amuse me when I was a kid was
one of the provisions of the Magna cata
is that an inch shall be the L length of
the king's thumb and clearly this is
fraught with difficulty because you know
which king and how do you get from the
king's thumb to determine all the
different uses of of that inch measuring
out fabric measuring out this measuring
out that but so this idea of
standardizing weights and measures is
important when you want to have sort of
organized Commerce it sort of arose with
with uh uh with cities and so on now
what happened for a long long time is
that different city states would just
have different units and so for example
things like pounds and ounces and so on
there were certainly way into the 1800s
there were sort of uh I don't know
Belgian pounds of weight and you know
French pound weight British pound weight
etc etc etc all these different places
and and there are books I I have some of
these books that literally list by
citystate you know the different uh city
states in Germany for example would have
different values for their standardized
measures and I'm sure it was a big can
of worms uh kind of doing trade across
those things now in today's world we've
obviously got things like the metric
system uh the imperial system you know
feet and inches versus meters and so on
and there's a certain amount of of uh uh
sort of dealing with the standardization
across that I mean there's sort of an
effort to Define International standards
the iso International standards
organization in Geneva I guess it is um
is uh you know has this habit of of
producing these sort of proclamations of
you know ISO some number that is kind of
supposed to be the world's standard for
how you know for the size of a credit
card or the world's standard for uh some
uh unit of this that and the other or or
even in some cases in like ISO 9000 the
world standard for the procedures that
should be used within a company that one
I find more peculiar and and really what
that ends up being is a is a definition
of how you how you kind of of how you
define what you're doing um more so than
actually sort of what you're doing so to
speak uh you know it's it's a it's a
kind of a a specification of a
bureaucratic structure so to speak but
in any case the the um this whole
question of sort of of how do you
standardize things and how does that all
work is one that in the past it was very
much once there was a state and it said
we're you know we're setting things up
for our particular State there's no
guarantee of compatibility and that
meant all kinds of things were
incompatible I don't know the the gauges
of
Railways uh different in different
countries in Europe and you would have
situations where you would have uh when
a train wanted to go from one part of
Europe to another it would have to kind
of be be you know stopped for a long
time be pulled off the tracks you know
different Rolling Stock installed and
then off it goes on the on the different
gauge of of tracks in the different
country and obviously more basic things
like which still haven't been
standardized today like which side of
the road you drive on and uh uh things
like what the uh Outlets are the voltage
for the outlets voltage doesn't matter
so much because we have Transformers
that deal with uh giving get taking in
sort of a wide range of input voltages
and giving out the output voltage that
different kinds of electronics needs but
it's still the case that one ends up
with you know different shaped plugs in
different countries so to speak and so
and these are things where at some
moment there'll never be sort of a a
further standardization because the
difficulty of sort of working across
standards is not so great that it uh
makes it worthwhile to go to the extreme
difficulty of changing the standard you
know I think um Sweden I guess it was
was a country that made a change from um
uh driving on the left hand side of the
road to driving on the right hand side
of the road and it's just one of those
Charming stories about change is they
did it at like I don't know midnight or
2 in the morning or something uh some
someday and they figured that will be a
good time to do it because nobody will
be out on the road uh and there wouldn't
be anybody sort of being confused by the
fact that all this changeover was
happening of course if it's the one
moment where a country changes what side
of the road it's driving on everybody's
out for tourist value to see that happen
so uh but I don't think anything
anything too bad happened I think people
just had that tourist moment but in any
case the um now question would be why
did why did there get to be
standardization for example the metric
system while that was Napoleon who
invented I you know to caused the metric
system as it is now to to get set up and
uh I guess the success of Napoleon
spreading across a bunch of countries is
probably what spread the metric system I
mean these different kinds of
standardizations another another famous
one is for the calendar uh which in the
time of the Roman Empire it kind of got
standardized to the Julian calendar kind
of put in place by Julius Caesar with
month like August being added and so on
and and with the most basic formula for
leap years being added by the uh
1500s the lack of the of precision in
leap years it was just assume the year
is
365 and a quarter days long but it isn't
quite it's I think 365.24 eight1 days is
the is the actual length of a year in
terms of the number of rotations of the
earth that happen during the time when
the Earth goes once around the Sun and
so if by getting that wrong you end up
with something where the seasons start
slipping around the year so I think
Christmas was by that point in the
summer and things like this and it was
kind of it was kind of bad and then Pope
Gregory uh kind of uh got this whole
collection of consultant astronomers and
so on to come up with okay how should
the calendar be revised and that led to
the Gregorian calendar that was
introduced in if I remember right 1580s
but I might be wrong about the the
precise date um the uh and that sort of
gradually spread throughout the world
but there are places where it spread
very very late like in Russia I think it
was still still at the beginning of the
20th century uh still was using the
Julian calendar and in England for
example uh notably happened uh during
Isaac Newton's life from from whatever
it was 1642 to to 1727 or so um uh he
his his date of birth is in the quotes
old style calendar the Julian calendar
and uh you know his date of death is in
the new style Gregorian calendar so
again the these kind of you know the
standardization of are you Julian are
you Gregorian uh obviously these things
start to matter when there's longer
range trade and if you're only sort of
dealing with people in your own city
state doesn't really matter whether you
have compatibility it kind of reminds me
if we if we want to think very
physically about it um when you set up a
gauge theory in physics you have this
notion of different kind of coordinate
systems that are operating in different
places and you have this notion of a
connection which is uh actualized in the
gauge fields and so on that kind of
converts You from One coordinate system
to another and I suppose this is a a
Charming human example of that is we're
using one system of units in one city
and one system of units in another city
and some there has to be a translation
between those systems of units sort of
BU Merchants traveling from one city to
the other that's sort of a a bizarre
analogy there but um with respect to uh
the I mean I think one thing that was
true about Merchants back in the day is
people who were traveling Merchants
spoke many languages and were very much
sort of able to to operate in the in you
know one of the things they did was this
translation from systems of units number
systems dates whatever that was part of
the story I mean I know when I was was
younger uh sort
of the this notion of import export
companies it still exists it's not
perhaps as prominent as it was in the
time right after the second world war
that was kind of one of the kind of
high-tech Industries in places like the
UK and so on was we'll buy stuff from
one country and sell it in another
country like you could do that with
textiles or something like that you'd
buy them from you know folks in Peru who
are actually kept the llamas in their uh
on their Farm type thing to people in uh
uh you know in in Italy who were making
fine uh alpaca scarves or something and
this whole mechanism of how you actually
did trade across different countries was
quite non-trivial um and it involved all
of this elaborate stuff about letters of
credit and these all these things about
you know how you convert things and how
you arrange for this thing that you're
buying from here and it's in this
currency and that currency and so on I
mean one part that was easier was at
some moment before currencies started to
float in value with respect to each
other there were fixed known conversion
rates like $2.8 to the pound for example
and that stopped in the 1970s I guess um
but uh you know this this idea how do
you do trade across different countries
it was pretty high-tech back in the
1950s 1960s in 1970s and so on gradually
things got more and more standardized
more and more organized things like the
Swift system for uh Bank transfers
between countries and so on got
established um things uh uh eventually
kind of the the credit card companies
went Global that must have been in the
1980s and so on 70s maybe to ' 80s
no it must have been in the what's see I
first got a credit card when I
was uh maybe 14 15 years old so that's
mid
1970s um and uh but they were you know
there was Diner's Club and a few other
credit card companies but the big
expansion I think was probably the 80s
and then you know it started to be the
case that lots of different countries
took these things now it's still the
case and this is you know when you for
example we sell things as a company in
lots of different countries and it's
really complicated and even you know to
take consumer payments it's not very
complicated for payments from
organizations and institutions and so on
but for Consumer payments it's kind of
like uh there are places where you know
it's they're it's very well standardized
and where it's just there are sort of uh
there are kind of payment processors who
can deal with oh that somebody has a
Visa card and they're in Singapore or
something thing and they're buying
something and it's all very easy then
there places where it's still very
difficult like India for example China
lots of these countries it's really very
difficult for to actually get consumers
to buy things in those countries and and
make payments for them and it's it's
quite an elaborate and Baroque system um
even even to this day and and perhaps in
some cases that's you know it's a it's a
it's a sort of geopolitical fact about
the world that maybe in some cases
that's even getting more difficult as
countries try to sort of close these
things in but um anyway a few thoughts
on on that
subject
uh let's
see pck asks you discuss the role of
ancient civilization such as the Greeks
in laying the foundations of modern
science and
technology yeah I think the Greeks in
particular well the kind of one
thing we have a certain lack of
knowledge about some ancient
civilizations because they didn't leave
kind of permanent written records so we
know a bunch about the Babylonians
because they left a lot of clay tablets
we know a bunch about the Greeks we know
about the Romans we know much less about
the Phoenicians for example because they
just didn't leave a lot of kind of
written artifacts behind I mean they
they you know the phenicians presumably
gave us a alphabet and things like this
but we know that sort of rather
indirectly uh it's not because we have a
lot of actual tangible uh documents and
so on I
think the uh the
Babylonians had sort of quite an
organized way of thinking about I don't
know number systems they did things in
astronomy they cared about astronomy
they recorded data about astronomy they
um uh they had kind of math problems
that that we know what they were because
they're on clay tablets and you know
people would solve these math problems
and they're very similar to the math
problems that you would find people
solving in you know Middle School to
high school today uh they would except
that a little bit of the V you know the
the the the word problems are different
you know X number of people are going to
dig a ditch and the ditch has these
properties uh probably in most countries
digging ditches is not what the word
problems in math are about but in in
ancient Babylon that was a thing for
those to be about and they had a few
kind of
geometrical uh kind of um figures that
were not as common today like they had a
thing they called it what was it the
cow's nose or ox's nose which is this
thing that is is kind of the
intersection the figure made when you
put four circles right next to each
other there's this kind of hole that's
cut out between them and they were very
keen on that particular geometrical
figure and I'm working out its area and
things like this but I think the uh what
what you see is these kind of math
exercises that were used primarily to
support Commerce and as a kind of a side
effect there was some sort of uh models
mathematical interpolation models
effectively used to figure out things
like the positions of planets and so on
why did one care about positions of
planets for astrology for being able to
cast horoscopes and say because it was
believed at that time that that kind of
the conduct of human Affairs was a Ed by
the the configuration of planets and so
on and that you know if if uh I don't
know Aras was in the ascendant or
something that meant it was a good time
to declare war on the neighboring city
state or something like this um the no
not Aries that that doesn't uh I think
it's planets were in the ascendant and
so on but um in any case the I would say
that the thing that really happened with
the Greeks and particularly the
Athenians well actually more generally
the the Greek a whole bunch of Greek C
States was kind of this in a sense
commitment to philosophy and the concept
that it was kind of worth recording and
worth kind of trying to understand the
World by pure thought and there were
many different sort of uh pieces of that
the presocratic
philosophers you know Plato Aristotle
all these folk the
epicureans um lots of different groups
um that sort of all got this idea that
you know one might be able to understand
the World by thinking about it now maybe
other people had that idea too but
didn't bother to write it down I think
that the uh and I would say in in Greek
times it was a you know it wasn't like
everybody was thinking about that it was
particular people but somehow that
became a cool thing to do and so sort of
records of it got Pres oberved and
propagated and so on and I think this
this kind of notion that you know let's
think about how the world works and kind
of come up with human ideas about how
the world works that's a very Greek kind
of concept and I don't think the
Babylonians really had that concept we
don't know at least of kind of an
abstract layer of their kind of
description of the world it was very
much people are digging a ditch this is
this number of people and it takes this
amount of time to dig this number of
feet or whatever they called them I
think they had stadia I think were unit
of length at that time but but uh you
know it's very pragmatic stuff at least
that's what's recorded we don't know uh
maybe maybe there was sort of more
abstraction that was happening kind of
on the ground but what's recorded for us
is just the pragmatic stuff whereas in
Greek times the the description of the
abstraction is also recorded and I think
that um uh it's um it's something
where that that sort of okay so once one
starts thinking about can one figure out
the world just by thought then one has
questions like what's the world made of
and the idea that arose pretty early in
Greek times is it's made of a large
number of copies of discrete things and
that's um uh that's kind of the idea of
sort of atomic theory and so on that was
um uh something that uh
uh democratus was a presocratic
philosopher who had a fairly clear
statement it seems although most of his
actual Works have been lost but sort of
commentators on his Works make it seem
like had a pretty clear idea that the
world might be made of lots of copies of
identical atoms and I'm not sure sort of
how people got that idea later on in
like first century ad lucretius in Roman
uh uh sort of science poet type person
who wrote This Book book called de rum
Natura on the nature of things a um a
kind of a it's a kind of a topic that I
might um have picked for myself on the
nature of things as a as a kind of
description of kind of how the world
works but uh he used as his kind of
model of this kind of atoms being put
together in different ways he used kind
of grammar and the grammar of sentences
and so for him it was like there are a
discret set of possible words and
similarly there is uh a discrete set of
possible atoms somehow and there are
rules for how these get put together
which are like the rules by which words
can get put together in sentences it's
perhaps an ultimate irony uh descending
deep into the rabbit hole here that in
our ideas about the ruad and ideas about
kind of Ral space and motion in Ral
space and so on when we talk about
physical space the sort of carriers of
motion of particles things like
electrons where an electron can go from
one place to another and still be the
same electron well in Ral space the what
can go from one place to another and
still be the same thing it seems like
it's Concepts which are very closely
related to words and so it would be an
ultimate irony that I hadn't realized
until this moment of describing it to
you if in fact what for us is the origin
of sort of discrete things that are like
the particles etc etc that the sort of
precursor of that really is the idea of
discrep Concepts and that lucretius in
his kind of poetic description of the
atoms that make up our universe like the
words and sentences he might be closer
than one might think that those words
and sentences will might might be like
the concepts that are the partical like
entities that exist in Ral space that's
a very bizarre rabbit hole type concept
but uh uh yeah concept about Concepts
and so on but any case the um I think
this notion of thinking about things
abstractly very Greek oriented Idea LED
to things like you know euklid trying to
State sort of geometry in an abstract
way rather than just saying look I can
draw this figure and it's obvious it has
this or that shape it was like let us
let us abstractly consider this and
deduce things by pure thought I mean
it's kind of really putting sort of
human thought at the center of things in
a much greater way than one had uh than
that appears to have been done before
but but we're a little bit prejudiced
because we don't have such good records
from from lots of civilizations I mean
Egyptian civilization I I don't think
there's a lot that is you know there
aren't the same kinds of mathematical
paparis tablets whatever that exist from
ancient Babylon where there are tables
for example of of of arithmetic
constructs um some of them coming from
the Babylonian education system uh we we
don't I think have similar things for in
the Egyptian case at least not as
systematically and so uh and I don't
know what the uh the the sort of system
of uh if some if You' gone to some
Egyptian and ancient Egypt person in
ancient Egypt and said so how does the
world work I I think the kind of answer
you would have got would be you know raw
makes the sun come up type thing you
wouldn't have got this more kind of less
anthropomorphized version of things that
I think you would have seen in the Greek
case where most of the story was well it
might be made of atoms type thing not uh
you know even though there was a there
was a a separate sort of thread of the
kind of Mythology of you know zos Zeos
throws the Thunderbolts and so on but I
think there was a a sort of
philosophical layer that was much more
seriously kind of thinking about which
wouldn't have would might have said just
for um uh for kind of a a manner of
speech or a way of talking about things
yes zus throws the Thunderbolts but
really they were thinking in a more
abstract way about sort of how the world
was put together and um I think that
idea that there is an abstract way to
think about the world is something which
has very much informed and created a lot
of modern sort of formalistic thinking
and science mathematics Etc I mean I I I
think the sort of the earliest formalism
of our species is probably the invention
of words and language where it wasn't
just pointing at things but having a
word that abstractly described those
things in in an aggregate way and then
in in ancient Greek times one had things
like logic being sort of lifted out of
the details of specific sentences and so
on and from from Babylon and then more
developed in in increase the uh idea of
mathematics and the sort of abstractions
of mathematics I mean I like to believe
that in modern times you know 20
centuries later we we have another form
of abstraction that's really very
important which is kind of this idea of
computation and this idea of defining
things according to rules and seeing
what the consequences of those rules are
I think one of the things that's
important there is this notion of
symbolic structure the idea that there
can be kind of a a way of representing
things that is precise we have that in
mathematics in the very restricted
examples of mathematics but this
question of how do we represent sort of
things in the world in an
abstract symbolic computational way how
do we talk about things like cities or
pars on the earth or uh sort of the
Interac actions between chemicals and so
on how do we talk about these kinds of
things in a way that has some sort of
uniform structure I mean it's as we get
Logic for example it gives us kind of a
a uniform structure for talking about
arguments let's say about lots of
different kinds of things arguments
about whether to go to war arguments
about whether this sheep is prettier
than that sheep these these the subject
matter doesn't matter there's this
framework of logic that that allows you
to talk about these different things
well I think computation is a framework
that allows you to talk about lots of
kinds of things in the world in a sort
of formal way in a way where one can
make use of the same Machinery to go and
make deductions man go and work out
consequences from the those structures
where one doesn't have to reinvent
things for every different kind of
things one's talking about one has a
certain uniformity of structure that
allows one to apply the same kinds of
rules TOS the same kinds of functions
effectively to different kinds of
structures that represent different
kinds of things now I have to say that's
that's kind of my longtime life effort
is building our computational language W
from language to um uh to be able to
represent the world computationally in
that way to give one a way to set up
these structures to apply certain
standardized functions to these
structures and to essentially work
things out in the world that way by the
way making use of sort of the automation
of our computers to to be able to do
that and I think that's that's kind of
the modern version of the ancient Greek
idea of let's invent abstraction for
things let's let's start talking about
atoms let's start talking about logic
that was kind of a notion an early
notion of abstraction what we have now
with computational language is the
modern 20 something centuries later
version of that abstraction that has the
extremely powerful feature that not only
is it something we humans can talk about
write about Etc it's also something that
we can get our computers to go actually
compute with and we then have I've been
describing it as kind of a superpower
that we get once we can describe things
in computational language we get to sort
of apply the superpower of actual
implemented you know wolin language and
and computers in general to to be able
to see the consequences of what we've
defined and so I I view that as being
you know in some ways a a uh the next
step after probably that sort of idea of
formalization invented in ancient Greek
times there's sort of an intermediate
piece which was sort of the idea of
applying mathematics to the world in
general which is a kind of a 1600s type
idea but this notion of sort of being
able to represent the world in terms of
symbolic structures is a that this is
sort of an idea of the computational age
so to speak an idea of computational
language I think it's pretty important I
think it's something that sort of will
drive the the future of kind of what we
might think of as science U where in a
sense what is the role of science
science is about taking what's out there
in the world and sort of uh and sort of
connecting it to narratives that we
humans can think in terms of it's like
well these things happen in the world
but we can have a scientific discussion
of what's going on we don't just sort of
say well it just happened we say we can
give some narrative some scientific
narrative about why it happened what's
going on we can reduce the complexities
of the world to something that is more
at the level of a human narrative that's
what the story of science is and in a
sense the as we try and represent more
things computationally we give ourselves
the opportunity to have more things that
we can describe in a way that we humans
can kind of understand through
computational language in a sense we can
think of the operation of the whole
world as being deeply computational
that's kind of the the idea that started
with my new kind of science efforts and
and now in our physics project that you
really can represent the processes that
go on in the world as comput
now many of those computations are ones
that are very nonhuman they're things
that we don't really have a a way to
connect to the kinds of things we think
about and the role of computational
language is to somehow provide that
bridge to to have a a sort of a a
concrete version of the things we can
think about that then we can connect to
the things that happen in the world and
I think that's it's kind of a an idea
that that leverages kind of of the
original sort of ancient Greek idea but
with this major extra kicker that we
have actual computers to automate it and
that's uh you know that's that's why I
think what we're doing with
computational language and so on is
important it's it's uh it is the next
phase in kind of the formalization of
things and going Beyond merely well it
seemed that way to me type thinking
rather something where you can actually
build the sort of tower of consequences
in a solid
way let's
see
um
gosh
uh okay David asks did Isaac Newton
spend a significant amount of time
attempting to transmute lead into gold
did he believe in all the Miracles
described in the Old Testament I don't
know all of those things uh Newton lived
at a time when chemistry was Alchemy and
Alchemy the kind of the Holy Grail of
alchemy was to transmute lead into gold
to take a base metal and turn it into a
into gold um because that was kind of
gold was seen as having some kind of
intrinsic value as it as it still sort
of has today um and the question was
could you just could you just invent
money could you create money well sort
of ironically Newton in his later years
became controller of the mint
essentially chairman of the Federal
Reserve u in modern American terms um in
England sort of dealing with the
management of the currency and he had
all kinds of cool ideas I mean he had uh
I think these are all genuinely
attributed to Newton I I don't know if
it's still gosh on a British currency at
least when I was a kid the the edges of
the coins were always serrated and that
was done so you couldn't clip the the
edge of the coin off because if things
went wrong with the value of the
currency it could be the case that those
pennies that were made of copper that
the copper in them was worth more than
the pennies were worth and so given that
it was worth just clipping a little
piece of the copper off actually you
could you could do that uh you could you
could clip piece of copper off and just
sort of still say this is worth a penny
but I've got some copper that I can uh
separately sell and so that was a sort
of I don't know debas that was H what
was I think it was debasing the currency
is that the no that that's a slightly
different concept but that was anyway
that was a um people clipping little
pieces of currency so so old Isaac I I
think it was him said well let's put
serration around the edge of the coins
so you can tell if people clipped things
off um another thing that was one of his
contributions was non-commensurate
weights for coins so if if you want to
know you got a big pile of coins and um
you want to know how much it's all worth
well if the coins if a coin was I mean
one thing you could do is just make sort
of one penny weigh this amount and then
a tence a two Penny piece or something
weigh twice that amount but people
didn't want to do that for all kinds of
reasons but then the question was if
you've got a big pile of currency big
pile of coins can you just weigh them
all and figure out sort of numerics how
much of each coin there was well if you
have non-commensurate numbers so for
example if you've got coins that weigh
one unit and coins that weigh square
root of two units then you can tell if
you've got 10 plus stimes square root of
two that number is something where you
can sort of take the pieces apart and
see how many ones and how many square
root of twos there were well Newton
apparently did that for the British
currency and uh back in certainly the 19
early 1970s I could say I had the
experience of um uh the
um uh of
uh I was I had somehow accumulated a
large number of coins and I thought okay
I'm going to take these into a bank and
I'm going to you know convert them into
some other into paper money or put them
in a bank account or something like this
and I thought you know I'm going to be
very clever I'm going to sort these
coins into you know this denomination of
coin and that denomination of coin and
the other and um the uh I take them all
into this bank and um they I think they
were still just they they say oh we
don't care about the fact you sorted
these just you know unsort them and put
them all in this this machine and it
will just tell us how much of each coin
there was and I think that was still at
that time working using non-commensurate
weights I mean later on there were just
coin sorters that would just take the
coins and just automatically sort them
uh by a more complicated mechanical
device
but that was a a contribution there so
it's sort of ironic that Newton was
concerned with I he was very concerned
with preventing forgery of coins and
things like this uh so it's ironic that
he spent some of his life trying to do
the exact sort of the ultimate forgery
in a sense of turning lead into gold um
he was certainly a do-it-yourself kind
of uh scientist I mean he ground his own
lenses he uh did own experiments you
know looking at the sun doing various
chemical kinds of things some of them
were not terribly safe experiments
although he lived to a r old age in his
80s um the uh uh but um um and he had um
uh I think that was um so so he
definitely had a a strand of doing the
kind of experiments that other people
were doing in alchemy um and uh and and
I think also chemistry although I don't
think made that much progress in
chemistry or in Alchemy for that matter
and uh obviously the fact that the word
chemistry has the same root pieces as
Alchemy is is not a
coincidence in terms of the Old
Testament and uh Newton's beliefs about
those kinds of things um Newton did have
some somewhat unusual religious beliefs
for the time um things to do with the
Holy Trinity and I don't remember
exactly what they were uh I think he his
his beliefs weren't sort of too far out
there I mean he was a sort of post Henry
VII time person so there was the Church
of England was there and he was the
Lucasian professor in Cambridge for a
bunch of his life and I'm sure that he
had to sort of officially sign on to the
Church of England um as being part of
Cambridge University I think he was also
later A Member of Parliament I don't
know exactly what the relationship
between that and Church of England was
but you know he was a I think maybe he
was a A trinitarian or something I I
don't remember what the whole religious
structure that he believed in or talked
about was but he wasn't very far out in
that regard in terms of the uh sort of
his view of of biblical uh kind of
descriptions of things one of the things
that is kind of interesting he was very
interested in dating different kinds of
events like one knew when various
eclipses took place he want to know when
did that actually happen in what year
did it happen and so he went back and
tried to sort of figure out
um the you know in what year did in sort
of in the modern Reckoning of years
which was by then the Gregorian calendar
in the modern Reckoning of years and so
on uh you know when exactly did the
Great Pyramid get get built or whatever
else or when exactly did the uh you know
the the the Jews migrate from Egypt or
something um when the um you know when
when did all these particular things
happen that were described for example
in the Bible and so he did go and try
and make an effort to piece together the
timeline of the Bible in fact the very
last book he wrote published after his
death is a book called The chronology of
ancient kingdoms and it's it's kind of a
hokey book um because it it sort of has
this rather face value belief about you
know oh the Hittites did this because
it's described in this book in the Bible
etc etc etc and I don't know whether he
quite goes into uh you know this person
lived for 900 years and so on um but he
definitely has you know he's he's taking
it seriously as a a kind of a thing to
build this astronomical timeline that he
wants to build and I don't know whether
he did that because what else could he
do or whether he did that because he
sort of firmly believed that that was
the way things were I I think that like
many kinds of situations one is uh you
know he was primarily interested in kind
of the science and figuring out the math
of figuring out you know when would
Hal's Comet return and all these kinds
of things and I think he was operating
in the kind of political and religious
world of his time I think that there
were things where he was just kind of
going with the flow on those types of
things as opposed to inventing the new
in the case of the mathematics and
physics he was doing and I I think I
would I would
uh uh I don't know I think as a as a
member of parliament he was a member of
Parliament for Cambridge and I think he
spoke only once in the recorded record
of parliament during the time he was
there I I think he was just I don't even
know why I mean I think the main reason
probably that he eventually became
controller of the mint is because he
made a better living that way was a
better job you know it's like like in
today's world you can go into finance
and you know it pays better than being a
professor probably um and uh that was I
think it was probably true that was true
in the late 1600s just as it's true
today and I think Newton it was always
he was a bachelor his whole life and um
he uh uh he sort of set up house in in
London and uh uh actually his niece
Katherine Barton was kind of the person
who sort of kept his his house for him
and um he had uh of an extended family
that um uh that kind of um I suppose
hung out with him to some extent
although he was rather a you know it
said that he was a rather daer fellow um
although when he went to the local pub
apparently and was sort of interacting
with the towns folk he livened up it
said um but any case he he um
um uh you know I think he I think he
became controler of the mint for the
money and perhaps for the prestige
because you know he didn't know that
Newtonian science would be a thing for
hundreds of years later I mean in his
time he was a a well-known kind of
scientist but he definitely wasn't uh
kind of the the prominence in those days
was much more in kind of in government
circles than in in doing science I think
it's sort of an interesting thing in the
course of history that different
professions get to be the cool
profession that everybody says I want to
be a whatever I mean it always amuses me
that for example Tech entrepreneurs or
were were not really particularly cool
back in the for example early 80s it was
not really particularly cool then they
became much cooler and and there's
always these periods of time when you
know being a consultant is cool being a
venture capitalist is cool or being a
physicist is cool you know I think being
a physicist has been reasonably
consistently cool since the Second World
War I would say being a mathematician I
don't know some countries like France
it's been cool you know it's had a lot
of cool Factor but you know it's always
like what are the what are the top
professions as a function of time and in
uh um in some countries today being in
the government the Civil Service
whatever is sort of the tippy top
profession that's been true historically
in different countries it goes up and
down in popularity depending on kind of
the structure of the country and the
government and and all those kinds of
things I mean I think it it was always
interesting to see you know what do the
cool kids want to do know in in even
when I was growing up in England it was
you know going into the army was a was
kind of a cool kid thing to do in
England being a journalist was a cool
kid thing to do uh these kinds of things
that you know that's that shifts and
changes over time um and uh being a
scientist well at least some kinds of
scientists uh has has you know in some
ways increased in coolness probably I
think in Newton's day being a scientist
being a science Professor mathematic
professor professor of mathematics as he
was was not a particularly High coolness
activity and being the control of the
mint was definitely much higher on the
becking
order Giovani asks what was the greatest
um technological advancement to come out
of the Roman Empire you know I think a
lot of civil engineering kinds of things
whether it's the aqueducts or the roads
you know these are these are kind of
major infrastructure building ideas you
know the Roman roads they still you know
the freeway system in England is still
sort of built on the on the a lot of it
is built on the pars of Roman roads
partly because when the Romans were
there and they wanted to build a road
the fact that people owned the land and
the way was irrelevant they just built a
road anyway and that became more
difficult in in subsequent years um but
uh it's
um it's a uh uh you know the fact that
they are aqueducts that are still
operating I think in it that were built
by the Romans is remarkable now it helps
when you build things out of stone but
uh you know this the whole civil
engineering story The the idea of you
know the Arches you can build the things
you can do to construct Stone buildings
and so on those are all very uh uh they
were all things that were done in a very
I would say artisinal way I mean we
don't know it wasn't like uh people were
computing things um it it was uh you
know I don't think it was somebody was
sitting there doing calculations with
Roman numerals and working out signs and
cosiness the Egyptians did know a little
bit about signs and cosiness and so on
um in fact the uh uh I think the word
sign is a is a Mis
transliteration through Arabic of
ancient Egyptian into going into Latin
um but uh in any case it was um and it
has to do with arcs and chords and when
you make the sign function the arc sign
is kind of the the the the distance on
the circumference of the circle the
chord is the thing that is going
straight across and I think the word for
chord I believe it's in ancient Egyptian
um transliterated into Arabic and into
Latin is the thing that gives us the
sign the name of the sign function but
uh um you know we don't know I think of
sort of abstract sign being done in in
Roman times we know mostly of the
Practical things that they built now you
know there are mysterious things like
the antia device you know this kind of
COG based computer from sometime between
the 5th Century BC and first century ad
that is presumably of Greek origin it
has inscriptions in in the Greek in the
sort of vernacular of the of the island
of sic um that uh uh but that was an
example of a piece of kind of Roman era
technology that was very singular we
don't really understand how it fits in
with with other kinds of things even
though for example Cicero does make some
reference to the existence of an object
like this in something he wrote but uh
you know I would say that the Romans you
know civil engineering was the big big
thing um I suspect there's some military
technology or at least some I don't know
whether you call it technology but but
um sort of ways to organize one Army and
so on that uh was also big for the
Romans I mean I think it just depends on
what um you know what what a
civilization emphasizes and Rome
definitely emphasized you know having
conquering things provinces you know
having highly organized setup where you
could have these roads going out you
know all leading to Rome or whatever is
the case those kinds of
things all right I probably should wrap
up a moment now because I have to go to
something else
um
uh oh I'll try and take one more here
from
LC
um asking about symbolic representations
and languages what do you make of the
break from computable mathematics in
1800s and 1900s and our current set
theoretic
foundations uh honestly I think they're
kind of a a wrong term learn I think
that the uh set theory the idea you know
what is mathematics well one can argue
that I've written recently a whole book
about the sort of physicalization of
meta mathematics and the extent to which
mathematics ultimately is a particular
way of looking at the ruad the the
entangled limit of all possible
computations and there are certain sort
of human friendly ways to look at that
some that lead to physics some that lead
to mathematics there are ways to look at
it that are sort of the types of things
that we humans can can stick in our
minds and think about as mathematicians
and there are ones that for which we
can't do that for which it really have
to grind it down to all those micro
details of all the things that are at
the level of axim or even below axim
kind of this notion that arose in the
late 1800s early 1900s was mathematics
is just this formal game where you're
putting things down and you can build
anything up from them you Hilbert
famously talked about you could make
mathematics out of tables and chairs
just as you can make it out of this Con
algebraic construct and that algebraic
construct I think that's basically wrong
I think that's not what mathematics as
we Mo usefully think of mathematics is
now one particular foundation for
mathematics that became popular in the
early 1900s was set theory and set
theory had Arisen in the work of gor
Cantor originally on the on the
convergence of trigonometric series you
have some sums of cosiness and signs and
infinite series and you say for what
values of these parameters does the
series converge and to a definite value
and the set of places where it converges
can be a very elaborate complicated set
and that led canor to this sort of
elaborate theory of of of elaborate set
theory which dovetailed with his whole
transfinite uh numbers story but any
case it came from the rather obscure
place but then it kind of got
consumerized by the 1960s even people
were imagining in the new math it should
be taught to all school kids and so on
in its rather finite simple form um but
the notion that sort of mathematics
should be based on this rather obscure
kind of thing that's very nonhuman that
uh one um this set theory I think is
really weird I mean there are questions
like the Continuum hypothesis can talk
about what it is some other time but but
it's a it's a potential Axiom of set
theory and we humans have no intuition
for whether it's true or not true I tend
to think that there is a way to
understand that for us humans it
basically will be true but that that
that's that it's true of our way of
perceiving things but in any case or or
the things we can construct that sort of
fit in with our way of perceiving things
but any case the fact that we can't sort
of there's no intuitive way to decide it
or or so it normally seems it's
something we just just have to assume it
or not assume it and it's very weird to
me to base kind of this thing that we
want to have kind of an intuitive
understanding of in mathematics on this
thing which we which is fundamentally
kind of uh um not you know doesn't come
from those kinds of places I mean it
almost feels like it's one of these
things where people say well the
foundations of mathematics is important
we should there should be very solid
foundations let's make the foundations
incomprehensible so they'll seem more
solid so to speak speak so we don't have
to kind of so we don't have to engage on
this question about are they intuitively
obvious because they're so obscure that
they'd never be intuitively obvious they
never have a chance to be intuitively
obvious so I tend to think that this
approach to mathematics that's very much
based on um uh on sort of the um um this
rather obscure wheeldin set of axioms of
set theory is kind of a mistake I think
that thinking about mathematics more as
one of the many kinds of things that one
can get from just applying explicit kind
of symbolic rules is a much better kind
of approach um it may be equivalent to
set theory in many many cases although
it probably has a definite thing to say
about something like the Continuum
hypothesis um it's it's sort of
equivalent in the same sense that you
know the gas molecules can have
different shapes yet the gas is still a
gas that obeys the gas laws even though
has those different shapes so similarly
you may be able to use set theory as the
axioms or some other quite different
Foundation that's more explicitly
computational as the axioms and end up
at sort of this human level at the kind
of fluid dynamics level with something
that is very much the same type of
thing all right with that I think I
should wrap up and thank you for joining
me today and uh I will be back again
another time see you then bye for
now